was machst du da hat mein handicap
obsorge
ich finde meine schwester - davon de
travers ist im körper meine damen und
herren dieser shop hat heute nicht mit
dem heutigen viel zu tun denken gesetz
bereit dem titel ein gut das ist der
moment zur ansuchen müssen
ihr seht schon jetzt weiter ihr fehlt
die bereit sind wir eingeladen bei denen
der debatte eine woche vor dem tag der
offenen tür wir wein schreibt jetzt
vorbei ich habe diese unfassbaren in die
jacke eventuell einmal versuchen könnte
einen kuchen zu backen ohne wirklich
jetzt rezept wie viele haben ist so
gerade an mir dran
gut dass jude befindet sich gerade mit
der kamera die hat das ist halt juni was
hast du denn zur allergrößte sicherheit
vorbereitet ein rührkuchen z
ich sagte nein passiert aber es braucht
meine damen was heißt aber trocken für
den kunden sind natürlich ja ja ja ja
das ist gemessen
die glocken jay kay freude wir haben
jetzt hier
die haben mich was allerdings doch noch
braucht ist die sache ist mache ich wenn
ich die milch grad mit ihr das sehen
jetzt halt ein bisschen ich weiß
wirklich nicht wie man einen kuchen
backen sollen ohne rezept also immer
dahin sei immer eine prise salz beim
ärmel haben ein zweiter was wir auch
noch brauchen ist würde ich mal sagen
die rente bruder verkörpert das ganze
nachher bisschen schöner zu machen oben
und wir brauchen natürlich auch noch
mehr damit weil das wäre das leben warum
willst du dahin
ich finde ich nach hinten film ist voll
noch da eigentlich sind erbittet
entwerfer zuckersüß ist nämlich ein
pfund zucker benötigen wir auch wir
brauchen eine kuchenform du hast machen
vor
ja aber keine kuchen vor augen hätten
nach machen ja ich mache nein ich habe
schon gesagt dass der titel kuchen steht
als wenn ich jetzt mal fürs backen
bist du behindert wurde ist der bescheid
und gebacken wird eine auflaufform kann
sich auch am besten bewegen ist immer
mobiler auch jetzt schaffen macht und
doppelte geschwindigkeit ja ich zeigt
sie doch jetzt die von der verpackung
eigentlich tun
hier steht die zehn frische eier eier
mit fell
ich habe noch nie ein kuchen gebacken
und ich glaube jetzt wird toll weil ich
habe wirklich überhaupt daran wie es
funktioniert hier
das hier wird unsere kuchen die rede
die rede dass wir unsere kuchen für das
sie wir unsere großen form von daher
kommt jetzt also ein bisschen würde
würde ich sagen dass ich das ganze nicht
direkt und das ist schon falsch
habe ich das wirklich so das handy
gesehen also freunde wir haben jetzt
hier vorne alles mit so ein bisschen das
ist das öl ausgetreten
was hast du da eigentlich an jude kommt
dass eventuell ja sechsten in den short
die bank auch noch formloser suchen
reinkommen ist jetzt auf jeden fall
vorbereitet jetzt geht es los mit dem
boden vom kuchen jetzt am boden davor
weil ab jetzt weiß ich nicht genau wie
es weiter geht also müsse er für den
boden machen dann kommt der das obere
teil und dann kommt der das projekt
wieder kommt auf jeden fall ersetzt ist
also der boden muss auf jeden tag nacht
rhythmus machen ich heute sagen wie ich
machen will also jule hat ein rezept vor
bereit ist die weiße das ganze
funktioniert jetzt für dich dorthin ist
anstrengend du hältst nur eine kamera
damit zumindest was daran so muss bei
uns die mengen sagen würde meinte gerade
wir brauchen nicht unbedingt backpulver
aber gemacht oder backpulver was ist der
erste schritt
ich muss doch wissen dass ich irgendwie
mache weil er verstimmt
kinder schokolade auf den kuchen
scheißen nein nein die butter und zucker
mit dem anderen gerät wenig sagen
wirklich der zucker aufgelöst hat die
eier nach und nach zu zeichnen zum geben
und weiter rühren
lasst einfach kuchen bestellt die mutter
hat den zucker mit dem handrührgerät
cremig schlagen mutter und den zucker
mit dem kampf ich habe keine butter und
ich habe keine handrührgerät aber ich
habe zucker unternehmen ich also der
erste schritt war butter und zucker mit
dem handrührgerät hast du was ich glaube
das ist so was ich nehme jetzt den
raffinerie zucker den ich habe und die
länder hat mir wirklich überhaupt keine
gramm zahlen oder irgendwas verraten
oder verhältnisse in denen das tier 1
soll das heißt ich würde sagen die jetzt
einfach mal einen esslöffel zucker aber
ich bin ja schon süß und wenn ich den
mache dann kommt doch von mir sein dass
man leichter wenn ihr denkt ich bin
lieber gucken spd
bei euch so ich habe jetzt gerade
einfach nochmal so drei esslöffel zucker
reingehauen und ich meine noch mal so
ein bisschen mehr mutter seiner frau
mama ich früher das ganze jetzt noch mal
so ein bisschen um freunde währenddessen
kann ich natürlich noch ein bisschen
weiter den über den shop wie gesagt es
wird fünf workshops punkte blieb
ach das macht das war ein mega viel spaß
hier es wird fünf normale merchandise
produkte geben allerdings auch zwei
produkte bei denen wir uns ein bisschen
mehr arbeit geben die allerdings auch
ein bisschen hochpreisiger angesiedelt
sind und die auch limitiert sein werden
wo ich halt so ein bisschen wo wir uns
sehr lange mit beschäftigt haben sage
ich mal also das wird krass ich will
nicht zu viel verraten aber erst dann
können wir schon mal im kalender
streichen
man fragt sich ja gerade so aus also
sind quasi ganz normale streit ist es
riecht ist er vielleicht wirklich nur
noch streuseln 2000 jahre später also
ich will jetzt hier seit 2000 jahren
und ich würde sagen nicht dass jetzt
einfach hier rein oder macht man so
keinen kuchen isst du wirst doch erstmal
den teig fertig machen
damit hätte wieder raus
[Applaus]
die ja aber wir mussten vorhalten
ich würde sagen dass jetzt keiner heran
und jetzt lebe ich quasi diese audi hier
drauf und machte die räume dann ruhig
das ganze rum wichtig und ich finde dass
er für mich sagen dass hier ein nummer
vier freunde
man ist jetzt auch drin ich weiß nicht
ob das also ich würde jetzt sagen dass
unsere masse mehr oder weniger gerade
fertig ist also dies halt sehr
dünnflüssig und wir brauchen eigentlich
ein ding gemacht wird das heißt mail
oder daher nehmen wir uns jetzt diese
tolle mail packung der libysche freunde
ohne mehrwert langweilig und jetzt schon
mal ein bisschen mehr doch instagram
wenn ihr wenn ihr dann entfernt haben
instagram bekommen sich lukas also juni
wirksam rezept steht das jetzt als
nächstes muss das habe ich nicht gesagt
wo düsseldorf das rezept sagen mir ja
doch wie viel an ihr noch nicht sagen so
viel mehr haben jetzt gerade drin ich
würde sagen da geht noch ein bisschen
ich weiß ich kann ja auch ich lege mich
die ganze zeit fest freuen ich kann auch
theoretisch einfach mal umrühren und wir
schauen wie es sich entwickelt weiß
nicht ob das was sie zu viel mehr ist
doch mal ein video wie solche die fresse
halten
halo hat über freuen würden nein da
würde ich immer freundlich die fresse
halten gibt man daumen nach oben
[Musik]
die dünnste kamera vor der welt sagt mir
wenigstens wie dick die masse werden
muss natürlich wird nunmehr ein wachstum
aber stopp jetzt schon mehrere lifte als
in mehreren städten dafür heute vorne
kann ja auch ein bisschen umrühren
erstmalig über im leben kannst du mir
bitte verraten ob danach noch irgendwas
hiermit kommt weil sonst würde ich aber
den ruf vorzieht
also das war ja das kommt jetzt quasi in
die form rein und dann im ofen hallo den
ofen da hier ein als wir machen
betriebsarten einfach mal auf ober- und
unterhitze und nehme mal 200 grad 180
der offenheit sich vor der tat bei 20
grad das ist ein zehntel von dem wir
heißt ich bin da sind jetzt zwei
esslöffel schoko pulver kein
haupttäterin ich weiß nicht ob das
irgendwie passend gemacht habe am kuchen
dass ich jetzt natürlich auch noch kurz
danke ja stimmt das sieht echt lecker
aus ich probiere einen bruder nicht
probieren nicht probieren erst am ende
schön hier rein füllen die masse und
dann am bass ausstatterin das heute
werden die rufe nach vorne weiterer
vorteil würde ich sagen dass wir jetzt
jemanden ganz kurz ein bisschen
aufräumen und das ding anrufen steht man
dann sehen uns herrlich unsere platte da
will man die platte denn die für mich
wenn die dann fertig ist alles gleich
nur wenige minuten später
das jetzt halt vergangen die sonne ist
schon untergegangen deswegen sind die
lichtverhältnisse gerade ein bisschen
anders allerdings haben jetzt eine halbe
stunde waren die guten hier drin
gelassen ich bin gespannt zuallererst
benötigen wir hier natürlich eine
unterlage woraufhin die tiefen stellen
haben benötigen wir natürlich
sicherheitsvorkehrungen wenn wir
natürlich das heißt liegen da rausnehmen
wollen das hat meine mutter früher weil
wir brauchen als mich aus dem bett holen
wollte und den kuchen
das ist wirklich kein richtiger kuchen
geworden sondern eigentlich nur ein
fetter käse er nicht parat galt freunde
wir schneiden kuchen hier jetzt mal kurz
beim start den wir hier in der form
einer durch und einmal hier noch mal
eben so dass wir uns dann natürlich ganz
easy 1 von diesem viertel stücken die
nehmen können nämlich natürlich direkte
das stück jedes stück ist ein stück
nicht nur vollidiot wir nehmen das hier
mal raus ist und ja es ist auch ein
bisschen geflattert und zu sagen aber es
ist natürlich auch ein gericht ganz
unten sondern sieht auch aus wie im
richtigen boden gerade aber so also ich
meine und der riet wie schoko muffins
und freunde das finale ist nun gekommen
ich stecke in den kuchen reine schneide
mir ein kleines stückchen ab von dem
kuchen den ich gemacht habe ohne rezept
und nun es kaum
es ist richtig geil wenig freunde wir
haben uns vorher ich habe zu ihm gesagt
habe nie untersucht die wenigstens ein
rezept hoffen dass ich zumindest ein
bisschen was ich machen soll
weil man stehe ich hier und macht damit
schade rein und anstatt zucker nämlich
salz das ist der hüfte und flammkuchen
den ich je gegessen habe
danke angestellte durch das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch irgendwie
gefallen das war natürlich jetzt mehr
auf inhalt beleihen und dumme sachen
text jobs machen als dass wir wirklich
uns das kuchenbacken gekümmert haben
aber es ist ein wenn auch sehr flacher
aussehen wie eine schuhsohle den kuchen
mit puderzucker rausgekommen aber er
schmeckt gut und das ist die hauptsache
wenn euch das ganze video hier gefallen
hat und eventuell oesterholz dass ich
mal irgendwo verpackt oder texte oder
probieren dann schreib mir gerne video
ideen und in die kommentare und sonst